es geht vor allem um dieses video dass
michael wendler gepostet hat ich als
laie sehe er hat abgelesen das kommt mir
komisch vor was sagen sie als profi das
ist schon sehr eigenartig wie er sich
nur selbst inszeniert hat mir kommt es
vor als wenn er gegen sich selbst amok
laufen würde
es ist eine form der absoluten
selbstzerstörung und ich habe die
vermutung dass das aus einem gefühl der
tiefen verzweiflung entsteht immer dann
wenn ein mensch zum
verschwörungstheoretiker wird dann fehlt
ein solcher mensch sich ohnmächtig hat
kontrollverlust ängste und eine solche
verschwörungstheorie die bietet ihm dann
die möglichkeit eine ganz einfache
erklärung für eine sehr komplexe reihe
zu bekommen die er offensichtlich nicht
mehr im griff hat so von außen gesehen
dachte man ja mensch beim wendler läuft
doch alles gut jetzt hat er sein jury
posten bei dsds hat eine frau in der
junge frauen der hübsche muss doch alles
toll sein wie erklären sie sich jetzt
diese wandlung vom schlager star bei dem
es wieder läuft zum corona leutner
man kann es im grunde genommen auch vor
dem hintergrund erklären dass er
innerlich in einer seelischen
ausnahmesituation ist möglicherweise
schon viel länger als die meisten ahnen
das heißt war so ist haben sich
offensichtlich große ängste aufgebaut
die dann auch zu aggressionen fühlen
denn das ganze was er dort inszeniert
ist ja letztendlich ein sehr aggressiver
akte er zerstört seine geschäftspartner
er zerstört sein umfeld letztendlich
zerstört er ja auch sich selbst und sein
eigenes image und so etwas entsteht
immer aus gefühl von grosser ohnmacht
und große angst und es wird ja auch
ständig spekuliert dass er natürlich
manipulation von außen erfahren hat
welcher typ mensch ist denn überhaupt
anfällig für solche manipulationen
menschen die sehr labil sind sind
anfällig für manipulationen menschen die
keine orientierung haben die selbst und
sicher sind
die könnten dann von außen sehr leicht
manipuliert werden
wir kennen solche finden phänomen aus
anderen bereichen zb bei sekten
strukturen wo menschen daneben
ausgesucht werden die sehr leicht zu
beeinflussen sind weil man ihnen dann
der relativ einfache lösungen für ihre
probleme verspricht also offensichtlich
ist auch der winter im inneren ein sehr
labiler mensch was würden sie michael
wendler jetzt als psychologe wirklich
raten
ich würde michael winkler raten mit
einem menschen zu sprechen denen er sehr
gut kennt dem er vertraut um darüber den
den blick noch mal zu weiten
ich würde ihm empfehlen wirklich mit
einer solchen vertrauensperson das was
jetzt gerade geschehen ist zu
reflektieren
dann möglicherweise auch profis von der
hilfe in anspruch zu nehmen wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren